[Musique]
on ne devrait pas pouvoir voter pour
quelqu'un qui fait partie du front
national pourquoi il ya pour des suisses
âgées assimilent le pour moi le front
national c'est comme des nazis pour moi
pour moi je vois comme ça donc je trouve
pas ça normal qu'on puisse voter pour
des nazis peut pas y avoir un parti nazi
et la salle alors qui dit rien salamé
elle est interviewée
vous êtes le boss le patron leduc com
vous fait tacler vous laisser personne
indifférent mais je crois que ça ne va
non j'ai des opinions un avis donc
forcément ça dérange certains pour ça
que je me retrouve des fois dans des
terrains parce que je suis moi même
les enquêteurs avaient infiltré la
messagerie crypté qu'il utilisait pour
communiquer mais impossible de mettre un
nom et un visage sur ce dealer très
actif jusqu'au jour où au détour d'une
conversation il publie une photo de son
fromage préféré un morceau de bleu qu'il
tient dans une main
à partir de cette photo les policiers
sont parvenus à extraire les empreinte
de la paume de sa main et de ses doigts
et ainsi identifier le dealer qui vient
d'être condamné à 13 ans de prison
le même cri tous les jours toute l'année
ces adolescents hurle arts à un signal
d' alerte traduction des policiers
entrent dans le quartier fait dans la
vie je suis policier police et ouais je
travaille au pot les scientifiques
travaillent comme ça non non j'ai une
petite tenue de travail en civil budget
petite tenue avec mon petit gilet
tranquille c'est bien ton nokia la mort
tel sacre il faut voir c'est poudre
noire souci [__] tu achètes ou connaît
la bac leur pic à la fin de la tp est ce
ça c'est quoi c'est à dire tout le
bagage il faut que ça passe que
on a besoin d'argent on fait des sous
vous avez quel âge j'ai 15 ans et vous
aller à l'école des fois ça m'arrive
kevin resta mais ça c'est un travail de
mec
franchement enfin je peux être misogyne
east mais misogynie star mais genre mon
ex marais qui produit des films que
j'embrasse les mois en fait il a fait un
film produit un film avec pierce brosman
emma thompson est en fait il me dit un
soir viens on va dîner avec pierce
évidemment je vais dîner avec eux et en
fait on
franchement le dîner se passe bien je
prends confiance moi bref je parle
anglais me comprends c'est déjà un
effort énorme et en fait on sort sur le
trottoir et désiré clément écoute c'est
dingue
son ex comme ça qu'ils larguent alors
qu'on regarde c'est james bond et
laquelle on me regarde et me dit matt en
mettant rien compris son ex est morte et
il me dit bah oui ait audio passed away
je dis mais pas ce taux s est passé son
chemin et me dit pas du tout c'est elle
est morte
à
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
esther benbassa et un pipeline étoiles
chez moi j'ai mon univers à laquelle a
manifesté des trucs qu'on s'emballe et
si tu me dis des trucs à 10 ans tu me
fais chier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
à
non mais je tenais été reloués je
t'adore été vu chez procurait pas à ce
que moi tu as presque dix ans mais là je
ne vois pas pourquoi je demande tu es un
gars londres est encore en place
je vais passer une phrase comme tu vois
tu vois ce mauvais rêve et je m'en vais
mais moi je dis rien j'évolue non mais
je pense que je vais pas les
désagréments de parler mais isabelle je
lui ai tout de voir un lien jean messia
je vous ai regardé chez pascal praud
faire bien votre gueule
tony et si moi je t'écris c'est pas
parce que je suis sympa qu'il faut que
tu parles sur les autres c'est
insupportable je parle ça s'est vu sur
les autres qui part je n'en ai vu sur
pascal praud fait extrêmement salure
pascal en gros ben non j'espère que
jeudi à polokwane
donc voilà pascal tu lui dis quand il
vient chez moi il est sage parce que moi
ça va mal se passer
les menaces l'intimidation alors que
notre caméra tourne encore
nous en faisons nous mêmes l'expérience
on est gentil avec voleurs moi je dis ça
pour toi moquait bien un jour il ya cinq
petit vont arriver ça va vous lancer des
parties doit partir sans accompli le riz
réduit le taux d'hormones de stress
il améliore et relaxe les muscles il
améliore la respiration de leurs côtes
ici le truc qui n'a besoin aussi de rire
et puisque c'est des blaze qui se balade
au milieu de la pampa s'affoler mais
aussi d'améliorer l'humeur
voilà si vous n'avez pas compris que le
scientifique parents est indispensable
de rire je vous fais petit orgue ans à
15 minutes par jour minimum ça devait
être une belle expérience ça devait être
un potage d'amitié et le tatoueur
indique j'étais grosse jeu faudrait que
je me remette au sport que ça se voyait
qu'on descendait des singes parce que
j'étais poilus pardon oui très
professionnelle ni tatoué ouais bah
c'était pendant le tatouage alors je me
suis tue en dix ans le temps qu'ils
finissent franc sursaut quoi sondés rien
inscrire sur vos capacités à faire
managérial terrifiant à son penchant
pour le cingo que je fais a dit alain
pochon touche un peu fade et suis pas
seulement ce que tu en penses
le film nous amène à nous nourrir les
débats par le tapage donc pas ce qu'elle
veut monter au piège d'un monde au
regard des voix la fermeture des bars de
roanne samedi dans les allocutions
images